la sphère des retombées de tchernobyl en
france le ministère de la santé indique
aujourd'hui que les mesures de
radioactivité relevés en corse en
particulier montrent à l'évidence
qu'elle ne pose aucun problème pour la
santé publique
il reste tout de même que le silence
observé par les sources officielles à
propos de ces mesures peut provoquer
l'inquiétude nous l'avons bien vu
avant-hier à propos de ce petit garçon
corse dont l'organisme reflète encore
des traces de matières ionisantes
philippe de ses skis après des analyses
effectuées sur des produits fermiers
provenant de haute corse en mai dernier
on a relevé les dose radioactive
supérieurs à la normale
jacqueline denis l'empereur journalistes
à science et vie décide alors de faire
venir à paris le jeune dominic
antoniotti et sa mère poursuivre les
examens aujourd'hui à la demande et au
chef du département de protection
sanitaire de commenter les résultats
docteur lafuma comment expliquez-vous
qu'encore aujourd'hui deux mois après
l'accident on trouve encore de l'yonne
131 dans la thyroïde ce jeune garçon
corse
on retrouve là le milieu de 131 dans la
thyroïde d'un certain nombre de
personnes en france c'est normal ça
dépend de la quantité qu'ils ont absorbé
qui elle dépend de leurs modes
alimentaires donc normal de retrouver
encore des traces dionne dans la
thyroïde un certain nombre de gens en
effet le jeune dominic se nourrit de
produits de la ferme plus exposées à la
radioactivité
mais selon le ministère de la santé il
n'y a aucun danger à ce niveau sur l'île
de beauté
tout comme sur le continent reste
qu'avec l'accident de tchernobyl et ses
retombées en europe on assister en
france à un manque de communication et
d'organisation le silence et le maintien
dans l'ignorance peuvent engendrer des
conséquences imprévisibles